everyone Steve Weintraub here with
Collider and I am here with the people
that won the Sundance lottery for as we
were talking at Sundance your film is
contracts are being signed most likely
and you're one of the big sales of
Sundance
you know am I taking the mic what this
has to be a crazy moment though because
just getting in Sundance it's a big deal
having like a standing ovation and
people being so moved by the film is a
big deal but then being one of the big
sales is like are you kidding it's
awesome is all I can say you know being
an independent filmmaker I have been a
filmmaker for quite a long time now
these are the things that you read about
you know the other people go through and
you know you have the bidding wars and
all the rest of it so it feels really
lovely to be in that space right now and
you know and I'm and I'm just enjoying
it and accepting it because who knows
the next movie might just go down the
toilet you never know I want to start by
saying how much I loved your movie it is
so so good one of my favorites of the
fest there's gonna be people watching
this that have not seen the movie and
are unfamiliar in it it's your story so
talk a little bit about how this all
came about this story and you know um so
I'm a huge Bruce Springsteen fan and I
have been since I was 16 and in my early
30s I got contacted by a publishing
company said would you like to write a
book and they said what you want to
write about and I said well they're only
two things I'm really obsessed with
Bruce Springsteen and myself and so I'll
write a memoir called greetings from
Barry Park race religion rock and roll
about why is it that a kid like me would
like Bruce Springsteen like Pakistani
Muslim kid living in a crappy town in in
Britain as I was writing I was thinking
you know in some fantasy world Gurinder
Chadha the woman who made Bend It Like
Beckham would make a film of this
because it's got some echoes of it she I
knew I knew her a little bit and I was
like she would be the right person to
make it I met up with her and then what
happened and obviously we had bonded
before over Bruce you know
we had lots of conversations about that
I remember and and so you know when he
showed me the book I was like oh my god
this I can make this movie I know how to
make this movie I know how to make it
well because obviously being British
Asian like safra's going through the
same stuff parents you know I get that
and then I also get loving Bruce and
what Bruce is about so in a movie what
you have to do is transcend the elements
you know you have to transcend your
British Asian nurse in some ways you
have to transcend Bruce you know you
have to bring all these things together
to mean something else to an audience
who is neither of those things a breeze
fan or appreciation you know so I think
what's a frost book gave us was a
brilliant starting point and then within
the film what I was able to do was work
with staff as we worked on the script
together was really help push him into
places that he might have been quite
nervous to go in the book because you
see what we do is British Asians as we
want to talk about our story but we also
want to protect our parents you know we
don't expose them totally you know and
so we're constantly trying to find that
balance and that's what Betty like
beckham was about was finding that
balance so it's a france
i knew that he was trying to protect his
dad and he had a very complex
relationship with his dad but he was
incredibly open and honest and you know
we were able to sort of really push to
get that story to really mean something
you know and also there are so many
moments in the in the movie that are
pure safra's 816 817 all the poems that
you see on the wall the most minerals
surprises parents one of the most
amazing things about this production I
just copy it
it's beyond crazy is it obviously came
from you the support from everyone in
terms of the production design and
everybody to try and make your authentic
so if you were to watch this film and
you to freeze frame on the scenes with
where the boy is in his room and his
poems and you zoomed in those are my
actual poems on when I was 16
I mean that's kind of crazy so so that
level of authenticity then linked with
your ability to be able to kind of get
deeper and I think our thing was that
what Springsteen does brilliantly is you
know if you listen to the river it's not
actually a true story but it absolutely
feels like ears and I think what we were
trying to do with the film was to have a
film which at times is fictional but
always felt emotionally true yeah but we
also you know like I wanted to use that
that interview you see he's watching an
interview from a BBC show called David
and Javed is watching that on TV and we
could have used any part of that but the
bit that I selected was the bit where
Bruce talks about the river and talks
about dedicating it to his brother and
his sister and brother-in-law who went
through really hard times with
unemployment and raising kids as the
question he's asked is who are your
heroes and he says people like that you
know keep the well going and it was such
a beautiful part of that interview and
even though the sounds really bad and I
spent ages trying to clean it up cause
he mumbles a lot Ruth but I couldn't
really get Bruce to ADR so I had to
clean it up but it was right for me it
was like if anybody doesn't understand
the man by now you've got to listen to
this clip and then you will get why
we're making this film and I think what
we've done is taken what we believe is
the essence of what Bruce believes you
know what he believes in terms of
America a better America living with
hardship finding your way through that
hardship and finding a way to make sense
of your life and and acknowledging that
life can be pretty hard but then you've
got to find the moments through it
because I think about Bruce is that he's
not a fanta system and so when he talks
about decisions that you make whatever
he's his music is one of consequences
you know which is why you know he's a
you've dream came true wouldnt that be
nice but there's still a price to pay
and this is a film that's also about
somebody who wants to get something with
his life but isn't sure if he's prepared
to pay the consequences so there were
parallels with what Bruce sings about
and what this character is getting going
through completely I
definitely have to ask you what was it
what is it like going in I'm sure you
auditioned yeah what is it like to
audition for a movie like this and how
talk a little bit those initials you
know the first conversations about the
character and it was relatively like
chill I guess like the audition process
and just like where we auditioned how we
auditioned it was like it's pretty each
other I think the most unnerving thing
was having to sing having to just sing a
song with like no idea if I was meant to
like flippin dance around or something
so I just sort of that was the most that
was tough in the year I made the actors
we scenes but then I made them sing for
to rap with you all night in JBL
speakers just sitting now on this side
and you put it on like blast the music
out and I'd have to sort of sing - that
was for the weirdest bit but it was yeah
but you did that really well
you did that really well it's almost
like you closed your eyes
and you went into the music because you
were embarrassed probably but it works I
was gonna say I would imagine that
someone had to be able to at least sing
with sincerity yeah it was very
important I think Thunder Road
Javad sinks Thunder Road - a girl and
like if you've seen Bruce life you know
as soon as that harmonica starts in the
intro the whole audience is you know
singing and then he stops singing and we
all girl she ain't a beauty but she's
alright you know we're all in there and
so that was like that's a big song so he
sings it and then Matt's dad the actor
the British actor Rob Brydon sings joins
him yeah and I know that's a big
sing-along moment but but the way Javad
sings it he says it was real meaning he
means the words and he's singing to a
girl and I made it his own and that was
important that was someone had to sort
of figure out because it sounds sort of
odd but I had to distance myself from
that and as I would have sung it you
know like as I could have like rift and
in done stupid [ __ ] like that I mean
like because it's not about that it was
it was I had to find a way to sing as
this kid would have sung and I remember
I asked Sarah I was like how do you sing
it how do you sing the song would you
sing them in an American accent I sing
them in a British accent because that's
important as well and safra's went just
a mix so I just like try to do it from
the heart really yeah yeah as opposed to
you know going off with lives and all of
that because that's that might have been
me or ever but that's not him and just
their sincerity with which he sings the
songs and and just some people it's like
oh oh that's a bit so some people there
might be that last bit odd that's a bit
weird but the fact that he does it with
such sincerity for me is what makes it
special and kind of sweet I'm very
curious what is it like casting yourself
in a man but I didn't see the thing is
this is one of the hard things for
sufferers er actually it was cuz I kept
saying to him this is great you've done
it then you gotta walk away because the
movie has to belong to him you know it's
not you it's him being Javed I know and
then once you do that every movie you
have to take ownership at different
times you know you have to do your bit
as a writer you do your bit then you
have to walk away from that you do your
bit as a director and then you have to
walk away from that you know let the
business take over you do your bit as an
actor and then you've got to walk away
from it and and vivec is relatively new
I mean this is his second job and first
movie but I kept and he was nervous and
I kept saying to him and watching I said
that's not you that's Javed your Vivek
that's Javed my only thought about it
was that I felt like because because
this is a personal story there was a lot
invested in me both in Vivek but also in
Kalinda who plays a dad like I didn't
want them to mess up you know because it
was so important that I didn't want that
for example that the big fear I had with
the dad is I didn't want him to be
considered to be a comical character and
I didn't want it to be a tyrant and so
with with both Vivek and and
what I did was I just spent time with
them and I showed the photographs of
what I was like what that was like
I showed them my poems and then I did I
think I remember you saying to you this
is just for you
you can totally forget all of this and
just do your own thing but what I'm
doing is just giving you material and if
you want to use it you can it was great
to have that sort of source material so
what I did was I got satirizes book I
read it had that source material talked
to staff has a bit met him went to his
hometown went to Luton saw his houses he
lived in and grown up in and that was
great but I it although the source
material was there this for me wasn't
based on safra's because I see safra's
now and I remember going to telling me
you can't base this on safra's now
because he's different as a whatever
year old man than he was when he was you
know 16 and ridden with you know all all
these different types of problems and
his sort of teenage angst and issues
living in Luton at home issues with his
issues with his dad so I sort of I used
that as a little a little bit of source
material but so it just went off it on
my own I definitely have to bring up the
fact that you got Springsteen to give
you the music which is you know he
doesn't he's not casual about giving out
his music and you have what 17 songs
yeah so talk a little bit about how you
got the music and what was it like you
know showing him let's start with how
you got the music well I think Bruce
knew no sephorus because he's seen him
so many times and he's best friends well
he's very distinct looking you know I
didn't have many my relationship history
was pretty poor in my in my late 20s and
early 30s and I spent that time and I
could have been having relationships
going to see Bruce around the world and
so I ended up having a bit of a
relationship with Bruce because I would
always be on the front row all the time
all the time persistence man what are
you taking Pittsburgh you know and so
we did meet him finally on the red
carpet of the promise when Bruce came to
London 2010 2010 he came over to safra's
and said I read your book it's really
beautiful and of course a France was
master and he lost it he says and as
someone had sent it to Bruce and I
jumped in at the same time and so we
were in one turning into film when he
helped us and he just like the idea he
said yes that's good talk to John and so
we've ended up to relationship with John
Landau and Barbara car and Tracy nurse
who are with him his colleagues and from
that we just because Bruce liked the
purity I guess of what we were trying to
do and the authenticity he just he went
with it
basically what we can say what we try to
do a thing was just think but not
nothing kind of naked way but it's like
what would be the things that are the
parallels and because Bruce would never
want a film that was just had geography
about how great he was because he
doesn't need that so but this is a film
Nessa bout the power of his words and
how his work has changed and affected
someone and as an artist I think that
must be quite a flattering thing and so
weak so the focus is on his word it's
not a body on him isn't it absolutely
but I think timing is everything and I
think we we approached Bruce at a time
when he was writing his book you know he
was mulling over his own legacy he was
thinking about a lot of things and you
know he's been very open about his
problems with mental illness and
depression and I think I think there's
part of him that probably really
responded to the fact that he had
brought joy and meaning to someone's
life when you know he struggles with
that in his own life actually and I
think I'm just guessing this now I
haven't seen his show read his book
thinking about our timing you know so he
was probably thinking about those things
and he probably thought yeah yeah this
is part of my story too and here's a
really authentic way of telling that
story you think about Bruce is that we
couldn't have bought his approval
because we wouldn't he wouldn't ever
sell 17 songs see you had to do it for
the right reason
yeah and so in a way it's the most
hardest thing that's also the easiest
thing because you just have to get
something
works for him it's not a matter of just
you know opening your wallet sure I have
a question though like I would imagine
obviously the film is going to come out
I would imagine there's going to be a
soundtrack how does that work in terms
of you know you have to work you must
have to work out all of that logistics
prior to filming
very close to production was Tracy nurse
who's been his contact with Sony for 30
years and has handled all Bruce's music
so it's really thanks to track Tracy who
made it all happen so anything we need
from Bruce we talked to Tracy and Tracy
comes back to us and or Tracy talks to
John and Barbara so it's been that kind
of relationship in fact last night after
a fantastic standing ovation and all the
great accolades and reviews and
everything Barbara and Tracy sent Bruce
some images some pictures of us at the
party and some of the reviews and he
wrote back this morning I went Wow he
said well good job best of all what he's
seen the film what is it like did you
send him a link like how did he see it
and what is it like for you guys waiting
for that reply because I would imagine
it's like the two hours of agony well I
was with him I mean I took the print to
him in New York to sit and watch it to
ask him afterwards if there was anything
he needed change it would like to change
and and it was nerve-racking it was
incredibly nerve-racking you know we
were tongue-tie just seeing him more
passes on the red carpet and one sit
with him for two hours and watch you
know watch how we had taken his life's
work content into our own I mean it was
nerve-racking but our intentions were
pure our reasons for doing it with pure
and that's what and and Bruce's pure you
know and so we we have that and so when
he started watching it I was nervous but
then I sort of moved to a position
behind him where I could sort of see his
expression a little bit you know the
side of his face and and I could see
that he was just really enjoying it and
lapping it up and and he laughed you
know the right places and he was shocked
you know he there's some of the races
stuff and and I think
and it was great we put the lights on
and he walked over and gave me a big hug
and a kiss and he said thank you for
looking after me so beautifully which
was like the most amazing thing that I
could have you know ever expected and
then I said would you like me to
changing is there anything you want more
of or less than he said don't change the
thing just leave it love it that
actually brings up I'm always obsessed
with the editing process because that's
the final rewrite and obviously you are
telling a true story but your
fictionalizing because it's a movie what
what did you learn in the Edit and for
many early screenings that impacted the
finished film before Bruce thought if
anything well what I really did in the
Edit was I did a lot of the work on the
music and the lyrics and it's bringing
them to life you know because we always
knew we were gonna use these songs or or
even less songs actually but in making
the film and I was working on it and
working on how I was going to do like
the storm sequence for example how I was
physically going to make those words
come alive then new things started
coming out and then I used new songs and
and when we wish there were songs that I
wanted to use but I didn't know how to
use when we were writing the script like
darkness on the edge of town but then we
were shooting a scene and as we were
shooting it I just had this idea that
I'm gonna just do a track in while the
dads talking in the back rather than
rather than do it as a regular see so
actually shot that scene as a regular
scene with dad's close ups and
everything and then I just did a track
in to Javad just trying to work out what
his dad was saying trying to get away
from it and then I put darkness onto
that and it works exquisitely well you
know but that just happened as we were
shooting but then other things like when
there is a sequence that Bruce really
loved and people responded because
they're not expecting it is there's a
sequence where Javad sister who's into
British Asian music goes to what we call
an Asian day-timer which were very
popular in the 80s where young Asian
kids weren't allowed to go to nightclubs
would get ready to go to school in the
morning but instead of going to school
they would bunk off
and go to nightclubs and being
nightclubs all day listening to
appreciation Butler dance music I meet
their boyfriends and whatever and then
at 3 o'clock get back into their school
uniform and go home you know and so we
have seen an Asian day timer and in that
scene Javed goes but he puts his
headphones on and Bruce's because the
night he's on in while these Asian kids
are dancing and suddenly the combination
of the two is incredibly powerful
because everyone thinks because the
night is Patti Smith song but actually
Bruce wrote in but then then one lyric
that we've used is they can't hurt you
now they can't hurt you now but that's
against images of all these Asian kids
having a blast having a great time and
so a film that's been talking about
racism and some of the racist you know
horrific things that are going on in
ages seven for Asians in particular and
our character goes through that you then
seeing them escaping into music and
Bruce's words means something even as
these Asian kids are listening to it you
know it's the power of words and music
and those are the sort of things that I
got really excited about in the Edit I'm
very curious you see the script you know
what's good is your first feature you
know how much is on you and on your
shoulders yeah what are you looking at
on the script and looking at the film
schedule and saying I can't wait to do
this one and at the same time the other
sequence is oh [ __ ] I can't believe I
have to do this though yeah the the
hardest I think the hardest had to cross
was to was to be prepared enough for the
read-through
and just even to be prepared enough for
that so I remember four days or so
before the read-through hadn't learned
any lines didn't know anything and and
four days before I went I'm just gonna
learn it all so I just learnt the whole
script in those four days or whatever so
I knew and sort of was on it was ready
for the read-through did it and the most
intimidating bit about that was just
singing in front of people just sat at a
table not in context or anything just
sitting in front of just singing just
like Belton
in front of all these people to set her
on the table which is oddly sort of
intimidating but they're great they're
great moments and they ended up being
sort of lovely sweet heartfelt moments
where you know some of the
self-consciousness that I had as myself
or whatever I had to let go of and you
helped me do that and in the end it was
just like we were literally running
around the streets of Luton screaming
screaming music didn't sound good I'm
pretty sure like sounded because the
thing is we got an earpiece in our ears
right with the music playing really loud
and we were like our grand that's
amazing and singing like screaming our
hearts out
Grenda in her cans in our headphones
just gets our voices so we're like going
mad like shouting and then afterwards
she'll take her I should take our
headphones off and be like yeah bit
pitchy or whatever I was like we don't
realize at all but yeah is that the
singing bit we're sort of intimidating
you just put Bruce over like it's so
joyous though there's those scenes of
you guys going around and singing and
the the change in your life and the
mentality it's just it's so filled with
joy and I'm sure you guys must have felt
that in the theater last night well yes
I mean what was fantastic was the
spontaneous applause that throughout the
film not just at the end I mean
throughout the film there were different
moments where people just clapped you
know and this morning the same thing
happened again and I think it I think
its reach you know what in the film
Bruce is the All American
singer-songwriter and he talks about a
particular America of his dreams and
what he wants and we captured that in
the film and I think the audiences are
responding to that like like we want
that America you know we want what Javed
wants America to be you know and I think
that's what I'm experiencing here in in
POC city that Sundance is American
audiences reading the film like that
like we're talking about Bruce and Java
in a British age
and whatever but there's something about
America as as Bruce sees it I hope this
is a reminder of a hopeful America and
hopeful idea of America and I think
that's what people are responding to
like joy and hope and you know you want
that from films don't you I mean you're
American gee do you think what we're
saying is correct no a hundred percent
and there's a lot of the the world seems
I mean it's always dark but it seems
like we're dealing with a lot right now
more so than ever and the film it you
know it allows you to see what we all
want it to be you know what I mean
but I I'm I got I got a stop talking to
you guys so you can do other interviews
I'm just gonna say sincerely a huge
thank you to Kia again the Telluride for
being such an awesome sponsor I'm so
happy for you guys being one of the big
sales of Sundance
it's just amazing and I'm so happy the
world is gonna be able to see the movie
you know absolutely thank you okay thank
you so much for coming in I wish you all
nothing but the best
thanks thank you so much thank you thank
you
you